I'm going to welcome up our panelists uh
first uh Drew Bannon he's the co-founder
and chief product officer yes of DVT
labs
hello Drew uh Julia Schottenstein
uh who's a product manager at DBT labs
and works for Drew
and uh Pedro Navid the co-founder CEO
and executive Regional SVP of Business
Development for latam at West Marine
data
thank you
cool so the title of this um is hot or
not and I think the implication is that
we'd be serving up some really spicy uh
takes on data Trends uh but uh we're
gonna take a little bit of a different
spin on it uh first I think we got a
plenty of spicy takes the other night
with Drew and Ben's uh Wings eating
competition
um but second uh I think we were talking
we all felt like there's a lot of like
cynicism and pessimism sometimes both in
like Society at large but also in the
data discourse and it's very fashionable
to be a Critic so we wanted to cut
against that a little bit and mostly
focus on stuff we're optimistic about uh
DJ's keynote this morning and even what
Pete was just saying in terms of
bringing new things into the world we
want to try to be as focused as possible
on things we're looking forward to we're
excited about and a little bit less on
picking on things so we're going to take
that as sort of the the theme we're
going to go through a bunch of stuff
that we've collected we're gonna talk
about stuff we're excited about the
panelists are excited about we'll also
do some q a so if folks have things that
come to mind you're excited about or
you're wondering if it's worth being
excited about we'll have a chance to do
uh some audience questions as well or we
hope to so um cool so I'm going to start
by just going around and ask each of our
panelists to start and tell us something
they're excited about and for the next
few years of data so Headroom I'm gonna
start with you because you're down in
the end we'll work this way what's
something you're excited about and
optimistic about uh for the next few
years of data I've been patiently
waiting for streaming to become easier
and
I feel like 2023 is a year of streaming
I also felt that about 2022 but this
time it feels even why is it different
this time every year we're just that
much closer to making it easier
um and maybe it's not this year but it's
gonna be in the next I think two to five
years at least that we get
better with streaming um the world is
streaming data comes in streaming and
then we just chop it up and make it a
big old batch party
um
it doesn't feel great sometimes I think
things might be simpler
if we had the right ways to work with
streaming data do you think like on five
ten years some some reasonable Horizon
like will even make the distinction or
do you think things will just work as
streaming by default
because that's the way the world works I
hope so uh I don't want to think about
batch it's just like a pain right
orchestration fact that data is just
coming in choppy and
we don't really operate in that world
naturally when we think about the data
coming in like you want to act on events
you want to act on things that are
happening as they're happening so
ideally yeah we don't have to probably
not because we're not that lucky but
we'll see we'll see Are there specific
things you're most excited about that
you think will be enabling for streaming
uh I think it might actually simplify a
lot of problems we're trying to solve
today
even if you think about a simple
Pipeline with a five-tranet DBT
Snowflake and a bi tool or a reverse ETL
solution
there's a lot of complexity because
you're trying to orchestrate timelines
between these things and you know you
want your data in your sales force for
with a certain lag and you got to like
work backwards to figure that out and
you're doing these things even though
maybe nothing happened to the data but
you just can't tell
some of that goes away with streaming if
you can materialize things and the data
is just moving through the system and
affecting things as it needs to then you
don't have to sort of think about those
things
um we'll see that's a very optimistic
take I hope it's true me too true yeah
it's gonna be great
um Julia what is something you're
optimistic or excited about
we're to synthesize it is the thing I'm
most excited about is data teams are
going to be able to do more with less so
what do I mean by that what is doing
more so everyone's kind of solved the
basic hierarchy of needs you have
reporting you have visibility into your
business metrics what's next
I'm really excited about data teams
having your cloud data platforms really
be that source of Truth to create net
new workflows to create data
applications imagine you have product
analytics to inform your sales and
marketing motion maybe you have more
personalization both internally and
externally customer facing I think we're
all buzzing a lot about AI people are
still figuring out how do I use that at
my organization what opportunities can I
see but I think in the next five years
that will become a lot clearer and it'll
be a lot more natural to have ai
applications building off of the same
data that's in your cloud data platforms
today and it'll be your source of Truth
so that's the more part and it's always
exciting to do more with more but I
think what is interesting and I really
am excited about I think it's possible
we'll be able to do more with actually
less
and so in the next few years I can see
us being far more efficient about when
we have to build data models and more
importantly when we don't have to build
data models
the work to author data pipelines takes
a lot of energy from teams today I think
machines will help make that a lot
easier you won't have to move your data
around quite as much and I think the
barrier for participating in machine
learning workflows and also
uh doing a lot of this work is just
going to go a lot lower so that's what
I'm very excited about as we get to this
new maturity curve of being able to do
more with less
that's awesome I love that
Drew
what are you you're gonna think that
this is nuts
I'm excited about data mesh and this is
a this is a really big 180 for me I made
a joke the other night but it's a true
statement I got blocked by the data mesh
learn Twitter account I don't know if
the person who runs that account is in
the audience awesome you're watching
please unblock please unserved his he
served his term yeah I'm trying to learn
um
okay why did I get blocked by the mesh
uh it's because I tweeted uh data mesh
is chuhi which is a slightly dated
reference
um but fundamentally like it was very
confusing to me I couldn't wrap my hands
around it I didn't understand why people
were saying these words that like didn't
make a ton of sense
and what has happened in the past couple
years is that you know we've grown at
DBT labs and I've gotten to meet uh
people doing data work at much bigger
companies and what you see is there
isn't one data team doing data there are
20 data teams and it's so big that
people on the one data team don't know
the names of the other data people who
get their data who they get their data
from or who use their data Downstream
and so everything mesh like clicked into
place for me it's about kind of
contractualizing uh what you expect to
get from Upstream what you intend to
provide to people Downstream and it's
sort of like a way of giving all these
different teams autonomy without you
know the wild west ensuing and you know
no guarantees about anything so all the
flexibility that the teams want but kind
of the the coherence the governance that
is kind of necessary to run the practice
I think it's a beautiful problem
statement I'm excited about
helping DBT better solve those kinds of
problems Beyond DBT which of course you
know we all love uh is there are there
other enabling Technologies or things
that you're specifically excited about
when it comes to
the data mesh yeah I think it's a very
cool kind of problem in orientation
because the technology is a big part of
it but it's also very much about
um setting clear expectations with you
know your stakeholders and committing to
a contract and making sure that you're
not going to change that contract next
week like these things need to be
durable so you get a lot of
opportunities to do the kind of
structural collaboration that's actually
necessary for people to do anything with
data and the sort of mesh constructs
compel you to have those conversations
like you have to codify your your
contracts your slas so data contracts
are the key to the data mesh like okay
there's a lot of words we can anchor to
it but as a concept the idea of like
what we do with web apis like here's
version one it's documented you can use
it in this way when we change the
behavior we'll issue a new version of
the API it's like just bringing that to
data teams and trading you know
co-workers as like more of an external
party that has to go through the same
API that you guarantee I think is like
how this stuff is going to scale
that's cool um I want to build on
something you kind of alluded to there
which was you know DBT you're starting
to work with bigger customers and I
think I have to remind myself
sometimes too that like most big
customers I see this too as we start
working with their customers are very
early in their data maturity curves like
it's easy for a lot of us here
the modern data stack world to be like
oh yeah you know a warehouse with
pipelines and you know now we're going
to streaming it's all old hat and we're
already looking toward the future but
for most big companies that's pretty are
you are you optimistic about the pace of
adoption and and the depth of adoption
of this stuff getting deeper
I think so I will say that
three years ago the story was a little
bit more crisp and clear and anymore
there's like a lot of Technology options
and ways to assemble them which is still
a good thing but
you know if you're coming from like an
on-prem database and the workflow tools
that you would use with an on-prem
database and now you're coming to the
cloud as an entire organization let
alone the data practice
you have a lot of hard questions to
answer about how you do that
it's interesting Julia Pedro many
optimism to be shown on bigger companies
yeah coming into the modern world I
think uh you know you have to relearn a
lot when you move to the cloud data
warehouse from running your data on-prem
but I think the question of like is this
a good thing is this safe doesn't come
up not nearly as much as it used to
which is hugely exciting for me and why
that's like something to be very
optimistic about is because once you're
re-platformed on the cloud
there's a whole ecosystem of composable
tools that can enable new workflows
where hard things just become a whole
lot easier
and I'm seeing it's not all at once but
take business units or TMS lift and
shift a big portion of their workflows
to the cloud and that might take a year
in of investment but once they're on
there you can just see a dramatic change
in the trajectory of what they can do
with their data and so I think the
question of like going to Cloud just
doesn't come up nearly as much still a
lot of effort but I do think that
there's there's a lot to be optimistic
there
cool anything to add nothing
perfect perfect no notes
um you said something about the cloud
data warehouse sort of being
this composable thing one one definition
I'd heard someone say about the modern
data stack is this just like assumes a
warehouse that speaks SQL it's just like
a bunch of tools that speak SQL at each
other it's like a little reductive but
um I am curious if there's any optimism
about dynamism in languages it feels
like SQL python maybe R been hanging
around for a long time SQL certainly is
like
it's funny to say almost gone through
this like Renaissance uh in part because
of cloud data warehouses and
Technologies like DBT is there any
optimism for new languages I mean Malloy
prequel there's like things that could
displace python like I keep having
people yell at me about polars like uh
anyone optimistic about seeing more
dynamism in the languages these things
speakers is there a good reason to want
that
I can um okay am I optimistic optimistic
uh prequel Malloy will replace SQL in
the next two years the majority
workloads like no definitely not
um but I had a cool chat with Carlin
earlier who I think is very smart and
awesome and he had hi Carlin Insight so
I'm just gonna pair it back kind of what
he said to me and it was like these
changes take a long time so we got from
you know writing assembly in C to
JavaScript over the course of decades
and the transition from JavaScript to
typescript took
six seven years so it's not a thing that
happens overnight but
two things happen one is the language
evolves and the the tool chain around it
evolves but also you get this critical
massive understanding of why different
is better
um so I'll say my personal belief is
that
SQL isn't going anywhere
um but I'm excited about the kinds of
innovations that are happening in
different kinds of SQL engines so like
duckdb has built some really cool
ergonomic stuff in a sequel that I think
is awesome and I think hope that some of
the principles that come out of
um prequel Malloy will make their way
into you know implementations of SQL as
well yeah it'd be interesting if it's
just further speciation of SQL that is
the future uh sequel forever anyone else
takes on languages yeah I think more
choice is always better and there are
different languages that do different
jobs
better and so letting people choose the
right language for whatever application
they need makes a lot of sense and I
there's there's a reason why SQL can't
do everything like some problems just
aren't well described in SQL I try doing
anything predictive or a linear
regression in SQL you can't so more
choice is better I think some of the
newer languages have some really
interesting properties to them where you
have better kind of relationships or
semantics built in which I think is very
very exciting and I hope that we'll find
exciting applications to use those
languages as well
languages are a really funny thing they
have incredible staying power when you
think of like SQL when was it first
built it was like the late 70s we're
dealing with a technology that's been
around for 50 years and we're still
talking about it on stage at a tech
forward conference everything else has
changed yeah
but it's often because of the ecosystem
that pops up around the language and
it's all the warehouses speak SQL so you
have the engines you also have tooling
around linting and the Ides
better
everyone has this uh learned sequel both
analysts but also business users so
imagine trying to retrain an entire
Workforce to learn some other technology
it's like a really kind of daunting
thing so when you look at just how
languages have evolved over time like
the top three most popular languages
have been the top three most popular
languages for the last decade and one of
them is Java so I I think SQL has
staying power because of the ecosystem
but more choice is definitely better and
SQL can't solve all problems and I'm
really excited to see some of these
languages try to handle like entities
and relationships in a in a more Modern
Way
I got one all right so I will say sequel
will maybe evolve and continue to
support some of the things it's not good
at there's a talk just yesterday about
adding metric to SQL for example pretty
nice concept well everyone adopted maybe
and then all their problems will be
solved and we'll be happy and we can
move on
um if not yeah then we get 15 different
flavors of SQL which
probably not great but
what are you gonna do uh
I mean the language that we have today
aren't that great like Python and pandas
probably not the best language is Wes
here I need to announce it today
[Music]
um
maybe types maybe nice one day to know
types going in types going out
um maybe there's a reason Java is used
everywhere is because you do get a
little bit of safety in there and uh I
think when you're developing quickly
maybe you don't care about safety but
when you're building at the Enterprise
level you kind of have to care about
these things so
maybe we get new languages maybe we just
make the old ones better yeah I'm more
in favor of improving what we have
rather than tearing it down
it's often easier and more fun to build
something new
it's a lot harder and more difficult and
painful to improve something that's been
around for a while but
we'll see that is true all right let's
move down a little bit conceptually
you're going to try to move us down
later this documention metrics I know
that's something everyone up on stage
here thinks a bunch about I am
personally optimistic for the coming
year and a lot of dynamism and new stuff
in and around metrics
um I know you all think about this a lot
I'm going to start with Drew who
Mr metrics tell us about are you
Optimist what are you optimistic about
in the next year for metrics Beyond just
please let's directly from metrics is my
father
call me Sam antic Lair
um oh God
so okay last session last session last
session of the week uh
I'm pretty amped about about metrics in
the semantic layer and I think it's
going to do a lot of really fantastic
things for bi traditional bi experiences
we have a very cool integration with hex
awesome that's good that's well
understood
increasingly when I just use like
operational tools day to day
jira datadog like the things that I log
into I try to picture like what's the
metric that I want to see from the data
warehouse in this UI and it's something
like you know a jira bug ticket that
shows you uh customers that were
recently impacted by this so you know I
could have reached out to for validation
or uh amount of ARR attributable to a
feature request things like that so
there are tools like you can do this you
can get this information in different
places but the idea of all of it coming
from like somewhere Central like a data
warehouse uh through consistent metric
definitions and something like a
semantic layer I think it will like
totally change what we think of as using
data at work it's not you know always
going to a dashboard and seeing a chart
it's in context in the tools that you're
using every day
very cool
I think your metrics is going to be a
big part of the answer for how we get
the elusive self-serve you know that's a
conversation that people have been
talking about in data for forever it's
like how do you get your business users
to self-serve and ask questions of their
data and get answers and the hard part
is that if you don't have some kind of
governance that's owned by a centralized
data team that curates maybe your your
top tier metrics ARR shows up accurately
no matter where it's queried you know
customers show up accurately no matter
where it's queried you're going to have
Havoc wreak havoc on your organization
and so for me I think metrics is really
exciting because it's such an important
piece of the puzzle to get to a
self-serve data team a self-serve
business and the data team can really
enable that by setting up metrics for
organization
all right DBT infomercial please
I share your optimism uh Federal any I
also fear it I love metrics I think
they're great I can't wait to see more
of them I don't know where they belong I
don't know what the right language is to
use them I think a lot more about the
developer experience of writing metrics
that to me is really important
um if you don't nail that then nobody
will want to write them and no one will
be able to
use them so if you can get that done
well and no one solved it I mean MDX
came and went a long time ago we've seen
that will come out requires a PhD to
understand
um and write
there's a lot of work to be done here
but I think it's obvious that it's work
that needs to be done so look forward to
it cool I'll move us another another
layer down the stack I want to talk
about uh storage and warehousing feels
like we've had the same big players
there for a while
is anyone on stage optimistic about more
dynamism in how people are storing and
querying data at the sort of yeah the
storage layer I guess warehousing layer
I'll start I don't care how we store it
and I hope I never have to think about
it I want other people to worry about
that for me
um
never been a conservative mind I've
never thought where is this data store
today I just need to know that it's
somewhere do you think do you think in
five years that like if you pulled this
room who what are you using as your data
warehouse I'm guessing there's a there's
a pretty good distribution of snowflake
bigquery redshift
and then a long tail of other stuff you
can bigger corporations you see more
like data Lake patterns it's been in
Vogue do you think though like do you
have do you think in five years if we
pulled a similar room we would have to
have those same big three cloud data
warehouses
I think this is your synapse will
probably grow
anyone who's a Microsoft shop will find
a way to continue to use Microsoft and
they're growing slowly but
Microsoft's really good at getting
better over time look at the adoption of
teams over slack now like
it'll be hard to justify not using it I
would guess in a few years Julia yeah I
think the cloud data platforms have such
ecosystem around it that'll be very hard
to change the top three and we'll have
like you know three to five that are
really meaningful for cloud warehousing
or for lake house or pick your your term
of the of the month but
I think that there's an enormous Market
to go after this space so you'll have a
long tail of companies that end up being
pretty sizable as well the top three
will be you know 100 billion dollar
companies and then the long tail can
still have really big outcomes as well
and they'll be purpose built for use
cases that maybe aren't best served in
the main Cloud platform so seeing a lot
of enthusiasm for like vectorized
databases that might become really
important for new generative AI use
cases we see streaming examples like I
think these markets are still very very
big and we'll have big outcomes there as
well but the top five they'll probably
be very similar to the ones that we have
today
cool
you mentioned the this you said
generative AI Jen am I getting that
right generative AI yeah I've been
hearing a little bit about this
um I think there's a pessimist case for
generative AI both like at a societal
level we were talking about this last
night actually and uh and within data
teams that like it's gonna eliminate
jobs your data analysts data scientists
it's going to take your job away or you
know all of a sudden you don't need
these people anymore
um and it's happening a lot of it's a
it's a fear in a lot of different places
but within data I think there's there's
these questions although also in data
we're very excited about generative AI
because it's kind of a data thing I'm
curious what's the optimistic take or
for anyone on stage optimistic about
what generative AI is going to do for
data
well we'll all have a lot more time to
go outside and touch grass grass have a
picnic
um
after the Ubi rolls in
I'm excited about that all right
to take
is that optimistic yeah it's good
something
I'm I'll say like I'm inject personally
like I do I do think that uh the two
things two things will happen I think a
lot of data work is a lot of tedium and
drudgery and like I think everyone here
has ever built a data pipeline or how to
debug a tricky thing or ever manage the
python package once knows that there's a
lot of head banging that goes into
things and I think that will
meaningfully improve I think people will
be able to spend more time doing
creative things maybe that means net
Less hours but I also think there's not
we're still constrained as far as I can
tell on like asking and answering
questions of data understanding business
context and telling a story around that
so I'm very optimistic of how we will be
able to spend our times
a lot we have to figure out still and
there's going to be an interesting
partnership between data TMS the new
technology and business users and how do
we have people be able to ask questions
of their data in like English or in text
and get answers back that makes sense
and so it's that same question that we
were talking about before it's like how
do you have the right governance the
right controls the right Frameworks in
place so that more often than not your
generative AI is helping people get to
the right answers faster and not like
getting a math problem incorrect which
would be kind of scary If You Just Let
it Loose I think there's very we're very
very early Innings and I'm optimistic
that we'll get to find areas where
genitive AI will be extremely helpful
with data work we just have to kind of
tread carefully
one one thing on the like textual
interface topic that I think is so cool
I saw this demo of it was like a blog
post it's
um chat GPT talking to Wolfram yeah and
you ask a question like how far is it
from Chicago to Berlin and it says it's
so many miles
and then you've read another question
like what is that in kilometers and it
tells you you say put it on a map and it
shows you a map of like the transit
around the globe and then you say change
the projection to the one that the UN
uses and it like shows you a different
map projection and so it's like this
wild iterative process that I think
we're always
seeking out in data and that kind of
fundamentally is better suited towards
like a textual interface than you know a
point-and-click dashboard experience
because sometimes you you know thought
you wanted to ask one question and you
realize you actually care about
something wildly different and like
co-locating those things in a UI is
pretty hard but asking the question is
is pretty easy like sometimes you say it
out loud and then you know close the web
browser and
uh go outside so I think large language
models will help with that fourth time
outside I love it
um cool hey
if AI wants to write my docs and tests
for me please do that I will let it do
that same
um
we touched a little bit on some big
macro topic there
um uh pedram you told me uh recently you
were optimistic about the benefits of an
economic downturn
which is a take I want to hear you
unpack that why are you optimistic about
economic downturns
maybe not in those words uh your words
wrote them down
all right I mean this was yesterday
right yeah there's a few beers in okay
what I will say is
if things slow down a little bit maybe
our customers will have some time to
catch up to us
um
things have moved so fast in the last
two to three years
in my Consulting work like I talk to
people they barely understand what
modern data stack is never mind all the
components involved
if
we can
take a breather slow down and give them
a chance to
build what they need to get some answers
and some questions uh
that might do us all a benefit rather
than accelerating the pace at which we
develop things because we don't really
know the right framework for a lot of
these things right now at the scale that
these Enterprises are working at
what we think is the right answer often
may not be so
if we slow down a little bit give them
time to adopt let's figure out where
these things work and where they don't
and fix those
that might
be a good thing see
in responses reactions
here I think the economic downturn and
what it means for a data teams is going
to be interesting I think data becomes
even more important in these times
you have to make a lot of like ruthless
decisions prioritizing constantly and if
you don't have data at your fingertips
to make good decisions you're going to
end up making the wrong call and so it's
really framing the data team as an
enabler for the business and more than
ever you need to have that insight to
help make good decisions
if I'm trying to go across the country
I'm driving I'm not going to go without
a GPS because I'd probably end up lost
or not not make it something worse you
don't want to make these kinds of
decisions for your business in an
economic downturn without the table
Stakes visibility and data at your at
your ready and I think it's up to data
teams to really advocate for their
position in economic downturns to help
the business navigate them
that's very well said uh is it
logistically possible to do audience
questions there's not like a mic to pass
around or something is there
uh walk up and hold her oh I have to
speak into my color
um if anyone uh you're curious audience
questions anyone have one um you could
also yeah do you want to uh I don't know
how we do this uh you have a mic all
right thank you Scott thank you I
appreciate the hot takes so I'm curious
um how you guys think about
fragmentation versus like monolithic
Solutions like do you think all of this
is going to slowly integrate into like
one big super company or you know one
like super stack that basically everyone
uses or do you think you're gonna have a
wide ecosystem in certain areas where
you have like a thousand different
solutions but it kind of does the same
thing like I'm curious how you guys
think about the consolidation versus
fragmentation yeah back when interest
rates were close to zero there were a
lot of blog posts about bundling and
unbundling
I haven't seen as many of those in the
last couple months
um it's a really good question I think
it is like cyclical in nature and I
think a lot of the real Innovation
happens in the unbundled you said
fragmented but you know
um in the environment where a lot of
people are trying a lot of different
things and approaching solving familiar
problems in new ways and I think that
one of the things that you would you
lose when you bundle is that you're not
really Best in Class at all of those
things you end up being Best in Class at
providing a solution and it's a valuable
solution in some cases but I think the
real Innovation happens when when people
get to solve like specific problems and
it's their their whole Focus
um so I I think it'll will oscillate
forever I think that's how it works
okay
cool anyone else
we're not leaving everyone's stuck here
until we have one more question yes way
in the back uh you mentioned interest
rates uh as interest rates go higher do
you see more of a shift towards cost
savings uh maybe something hasn't been
discussed as much this week
pick that uh yes definitely I think
people are conscious of costs and
looking at ways to improve I don't think
people are cutting out data altogether
and saying we're not doing this anymore
but I think the freewheeling nature of
things of the past two years has kind of
slowed down
um in my conversations companies
they're focusing again on like wait what
are the actual Essentials of a data
stack and why are we doing this rather
than just giving free reins to everyone
to do whatever they want which again I
think is a good thing
um I don't think we're well served if
anyone is just wasting their time on a
data stack that creates a lot of like
confusion and doubt about the merits of
it but maybe in this environment if we
focus on
where do we actually provide value
and if we can actually approve that then
I think long term that does better
for everyone
just to Riff on that quickly like we
talked about uh in your words benefits
of the economic downturn uh I believe
that was the post and I'm sure everyone
knows that's parents take and
um I don't know I I this is the first
time I've been a co-founder of a company
in an economic climate quite like this
one maybe some of you same boat
um but it does feel pretty clear that if
you can make it through this era or if
you're starting a company and you can
exist on the other side you will have
been like forged in the fire
um and you can kind of assume that that
you got the right you're solving the
right problems for for real customers
um so I think that's a real benefit like
that's me as a as a product leader
people using DBT today to help solve
these really important problems I have a
lot of confidence that they're going to
keep using it a couple years from now
too
yeah I think
personally I think the
focus on costumes is healthy like I
think that there was a lot of
proliferation of stuff
proliferation to startups proliferation
of
technology professional people's using
stuff without a lot of thought and Care
on it and I think that actually caused
some problems in its own way so
um
it's it's painful and like yes you do
see like just as a vendor yeah you see
people focused on cost savings yeah it's
true probably for everyone but I don't
think it's like
uh I think there's like a healthiness to
it as well
cool we got uh I saw that I saw your
hand first so you're at you're next
here we go oh unless Scott do you have
someone sorry
sorry okay okay
thanks
um I I think it's interesting when you
hear about companies being described as
you know product LED or engineering-led
sales LED curious who you guys see as
maybe a data-led company or a data-led
organization
uh if that exists or if it doesn't like
what that looks like from your
perspective I have a I have a kind of I
have a little bit of a hot take on this
um I used to work with a lot of big
financial services companies like Banks
I think banks figured out way before
anyone else that they were data
companies like the financial services
has a massive data uh like economy like
like industry like Bloomberg is a
massive company it basically just sells
data to financial services companies
and if you look at a lot of the things
that Banks do fundamentally it's like
looking at data building models and
understanding risk Based on data and
like almost everyone in a bank at some
level is a data worker and so it's
interesting uh I think because it's it's
not like necessarily fungible to other
Industries as much but I do think having
worked with with banks that always
struck me that they were data-led
companies they realized that their
business actually just really is
mostly data and understanding the world
through data so
you worked at a bank does that resonate
with you I did and uh there was
definitely a lot of data a lot of Terror
data
um which I heard it's coming back this
year so we'll see here it is back there
it is it's an optimistic date she should
have called that one out I mentioned
dynamism and storage why don't you bring
up territory why not right we used to
ship well they used to ship giant
mainframes to it was literally a
warehouse basically to get a Mainframe
uh maybe that's going away but
Banks we're definitely data driven I
remember in 2008 we saw like the biggest
threat to us we're not other Banks it
was Apple like data and Tech were the
biggest things that we think about
interesting Julia it sounded like you
would think yeah my mind went to fintech
companies or Banks and then also
operationally intensive companies that
have very complex set of things that
need to happen where like a minor
Improvement in their operational
efficiencies have a really big business
impact so think of like all of the
delivery company is at scale they're
very very Savvy with data because it
matters for their business so whenever
you can uh you have to care a lot about
margin uh data becomes really really
important
all right we'll try to do another one or
two questions uh
uh quickish
question for Drew about his optimism for
data mesh
um
so cross team governance the problem has
existed for a while so what gives you
optimism that it's going to be
automation this time and not process
what are you working on to address it
it's a really good question it's
humbling to you know always keep in the
back of our heads that old problems new
Solutions and I kind of like Julius
framing of uh do more with less I think
that you know
you can uh create a cube you you could
have created a cube you know 10 15 20
years ago and and that could be a way to
scale out collaboration but the idea of
doing that in a way that's also very
flexible in which you have a lot more
control and autonomy as a team and a lot
of the companies were talking to these
days are interested in moving the
responsibility of data to the the teams
that produce the data
uh we're we're on the product team here
I'm like a little dubious of the data
product manager role I don't know we'll
see if that shakes out but just the idea
of moving it closer to the producers of
the data they're the ones with the
context getting them plugged into how
people are going to use the stuff
Downstream and
I think that's really exciting I think
it's empowering I think it's one of
those places where the technology makes
it possible to operate at that level
versus the like
satisficing like make the thing work at
all which is I think where we have kind
of bid for
for the past couple decades
cool one more question
yeah so what advice do you have to
master students graduating in this
economy so is that what advice do you
have for students yeah graduating in
this economy
did you just graduate I mean we're
graduating in two months okay early
congratulations one month yeah great
work yeah
yeah
um
learn about large language models
apparently that's all that matters yeah
right uh take up art and writing I
started working in 2007 right before the
2008 crisis at a bank
um
visit tech support it was a part-time
job while in school
it was very tough but I would say just
get in somewhere and then do what you
want once you're in there
it's really hard to go from college to
your dream job it's really easy to go
from a company to something you really
like uh
a lot of companies are looking for
people who
are passionate and want to do things
they just don't know who that person is
so if you have a way in
it may not be the perfect job for you
but you can bring data to almost any
role these days so
that might work I would Embrace side
projects
um
as someone who looks at a good amount of
resumes it's like a lot of resumes will
like generally look the same but it's
always cool if you can see something
someone's built especially I don't know
if you're in like a more technical field
or you know interested in data but like
you know put stuff on GitHub put stuff
out on the internet use
Cool Tools to build something neat and
publish it publicly like
that stuff's all at your fingertips and
I think it's a good way to show that
you're interested in something and that
you're if you're legitimately passionate
about it go work on it and people will
see that and write about it too I think
uh if you can write
you already stand out from 95 of people
out there well humans don't need to
write anymore right that's all I do
that's right yeah they're coming chat
cbc's come for your job first buddy I'm
ready
be outside more cool well I'm seeing the
flashing lights it means we're out of
time uh I want to thank everyone again
for sticking around to the last session
of the week I want to thank Pete again
for organizing this and doing such a
great job and being such a great Steward
for the data Community that's meaningful
to so many of us
and I will look forward to seeing you
all if not before a year from now back
in Austin we're doing this to here again
right right here 365 days from now
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]